he wasn't there yet but the Beatles were
looking for a photo op and I think that
day in February 1964 was really me the
Beatles and Cassius Clay that was the
beginning of the 60s I am Nicholas beer
with reason TV and today we're talking
with Robert Lipsyte he's a legendary
widely acclaimed sports writer novelist
and now he's going to be ESPN's new
Ombudsman come June 1st
Bob thanks for talking to us my pleasure
you know what old reasons subscribe I'm
very happy I wrote recently when I read
about you becoming to see a ESPN's
Ombudsman that chances are people have
read something that you've written
whether they like sports or hate sports
because you know for the past 45 or 50
years I mean you've been writing really
insightful and wide-ranging essays about
sports a young adult novels my personal
favorite is the contender which I was
forced to read and it was one of those
books that made me understand required
reading isn't always terrible other
people love one fat summer let's talk
first about ESPN your role as Ombudsman
what will you be what will you be doing
well that's a very good question any
suggestion you have are welcome I'm the
fifth one mm-hmm
everyone before has done it entirely
differently I suspect that I will do it
the same way I wrote sports columns and
City columns you do some reporting and
how do that emerge as a break now will
you be taking cues I mean will it be
your interests or will it be reader
interest well ultimately I'll have to be
interested yeah but I the first pass
really will come out of the email bag
mm-hm what what people are interested in
that's always dangerous of course
because they're mostly complaining about
something but maybe there's something to
complain about
what are your main areas of interests
and contemporary sports kind of culture
right now what do you what what else you
I mean ESPN is a very important because
for most people I think it's the main
window
on to sports and sports culture and we
probably agree that sports is important
yeah as a definer of values all the
years that I have written witheringly
about ESPN for which I've also worked on
saying it's been the conflict of
interest wondering how you deal with
that interface where you or fiduciary
partners in the game right and then you
are supposedly covering it in any kind
of honest journalistic how do you think
ESPN has been doing is this a necessary
conflict and are they doing a pretty
good job
Shirley's necessary conflict if they're
going to have any kind of journalism
presence which is probably a good thing
for them to have a couple of weeks ago I
probably would you know trash ESPN now
that their past couple of weeks from not
no no what I realize now is that I all
these years haven't had access I mean
they're not giving me subpoena power as
far as I know but I I believe that
anybody at ESPN who doesn't answer my
call it's a guilty plea so I hope to get
to the bottom of it I mean a very good
example they you know before my watch of
course is Jason Collins comes out okay
and this is the NBA player who is I
guess the first more or less active
player like the professional sports
league male to come out as gay right and
one of their prime NBA reporters in
discussing it a couple of days later
said that homosexuals are walking in
open rebellion to God and Jesus Christ
he's also against premarital sex right
any kind of sex right unless it's
between a married man and a woman the
basic question is was he led into that
statement on ESPN show where he was
asked what his personal views were was
it a declaration and
white paper why would that matter I
think about her a lot I don't know
certainly in any kind of standards and
practices does a reporter have the
privilege of an opinion about something
that we expect he's covering whatever
objectively means so it would matter it
was a columnist right he would in trying
to kind of speak to a broad on it's a
sports covers should they have people
who think that homosexuality is against
God's will because that would reflect
part of it as well casting in America
yeah a big chunk of the population feels
that way you but no freedom of speech I
think people have a right to be wrong
right but the question is within a
journalistic con struct is that
appropriate and so you've talked about I
mean that's partly your your gonna try
and bring more transparency I mean
that's the role of the aisle I consider
myself the window washer yeah with ESPN
as a kind of institution do you feel it
I always thought that in a way I mean
early on especially it seems snarky but
that was very different and was very
refreshing in sports coverage because
for a long time I think you and a number
of other people were different than kind
of typical sports writers and that they
brought some edge and some critical
distance or some irony to the games or
in the industries that they covered do
you think overall ESPN has been a
positive influence on the way that we
talk about well you're talking about
it's very specific time in ESPN's career
when it wasn't
yes pure now we're talking about Keith
Olbermann and Dan Patrick in particular
who had their own Sports Center
Charlotte and they had not been told
that irony he was over right north
sarcasm or parity or anything like that
and they were refreshing no I certainly
compared to you know most of the ex-jock
blue haired guys on television they were
wonderful
ESPN ultimately I think became
uncomfortable with that as they became
more institutionalized
as they got into bed with the league's
and ultimately as we know now they are
probably the main donors for ABC in
business so that no longer exists was
ESPN a positive force well let's take a
step back in sports a positive force in
America sometimes it is and sometimes
it's not I guess a lot of the sports
that ESPN and the other networks cover
is not a positive force any more than
any other kind of entertainment this is
two levels of sports in America one is
of course celebrity sports and the other
is what you do with your body in public
right where do you go now for good
sports ready what are your favorite
writers or places sites I I think that
there's more good sports writing and
there's ever been more smart intelligent
people
the only person however who I never fail
to read is Dave Zirin I think that he's
brought something absolutely new and
fresh in here bizarrely the sports
editor of the nation yeah that's well
what do you like what what's he bringing
that what every everything is
politically based right hi he covers
nothing without giving us it's its
political ramifications in in that sense
I think he could be seen as a kind of
protege of you were an epic on of you
already like to do so well because this
is much harder and struggling in those
areas than I ever was
but I would like to take a piece yes
well I mean one of the things that you
did early on in a way that was kind of
unannounced and thankfully gained a wide
readership but that you you were talking
before about sports you know has
multiple levels but you didn't treat
sports as a world unto itself it's
really important as a kind of reflector
of American culture and it creates a
feedback loop where with what happens in
sports affects us and throughout culture
politics you name it business and vice
versa so let's talk a little bit about
that reason is in its 45th year of
existing
we started in 1968 by a guy who I don't
read you for your support that's right
that's probably a wise a wise decision
you know set the scene for us in you
know mid 60's when you started sports
writing what was the expectation when
when people looked at sports and when
people read about sports what were they
after what were they interested in the
quintessential event where I also
believe the 60s began with Muhammad Ali
fighting Sonny Liston the Heavyweight
Championship here was a 22 year old
boxer never beaten anybody of note had
no reason in the world to be fighting
the heavyweight champion but boxing
needed a sacrificial version for the Box
on it even wasn't even a true
heavyweight really at that point or he
had just bumped off he'd won the light
heavyweight title in Olympics rikes t he
was on he had been on the cover of Time
magazine
well now read something but that was
only because of the bad poetry and he
didn't even write that he was reading in
coffee houses so here he comes to fight
the heavyweight championship seven two
one arms and Sonny Liston I mean for
those of us or for our viewers who don't
remember who Sonny Liston is who was the
sunny one I think Sonny Liston was with
Grendel's mother Sonny Liston was the
unbeatable book he'd come out of prison
to knock everybody out the N double AC
begged other black fighters not to fight
him because it would be bad for the
movement he was just kind of a glowering
and - he was famous for not really being
particularly talkative or talked glared
a lot he is his fist is talking for me
generally knock people out in the first
round which is which is what made my
career when Cassius Clay as Muhammad Ali
was then called went to fight Liston the
real boxing writer
didn't really think it was worth his
time so he decided to send a kid from
night rewrite and that was me and my
instructions were as soon as I got to
Miami is rent a car and drive back and
forth between the arena where the fight
was going to be held and the nearest
hospital so I would waste no deadline so
I'm following Cassius Clay into
intensive care which I did I went to his
that day that same day I parked and and
went to his gym where he worked out he
wasn't there yet but the Beatles were
looking for a photo op and I think that
day in February 1964 was really me the
Beatles and Cassius that was the
beginning of the sixties you know and
you're kind of oh you're the only one
who still got it together down to well
we were all together in the same room
the six of us I was the fifth Beatle but
also lurking out in the neighborhood was
Malcolm X who had been asked to keep a
low profile in return for two tickets to
the fight because the promoter was
afraid that people wouldn't come if they
knew that Cassius Clay was on his way
becoming a Muslim when you showed up
there did you realize that this is you
know this isn't about a boxing match
this is about a we're about to enter a
new world where Cassius Clay can
reinvent himself as Muhammad Ali and you
know the Beatles made many more no I was
quite more grandiose than that yeah I
thought this was a chance for me to get
by light in the papers other I was
totally careerist I mean this was very
exciting for a kid off-night rewrite to
get what you know some feature stories
and you know the deals were great no and
all he was wonderful clay we were about
the same age it was a real age gap
most of the reporters and columnists
down it was a heavyweight fight after
were older men older white men
and they were all in Sonny Liston's camp
run where Joe Lewis was the great waters
well yeah talk about that because one of
the things that is fascinating it and
especially if you come to Ollie after he
is
you know the heavyweight champion the
king of all kings and whatnot it's hard
to believe that sports writers weren't
always falling over themselves praising
him and trying to kind of sniff his jock
why did sports writers dislike Muhammad
Oh Eric Cassius Clay's well first of all
on the most basic level
he was an unorthodox fighter the
received wisdom is that the only way to
box was by slipping punches which
basically meant you Luke your head one
side to the other and and the punch
harmlessly travels he leaned backwards
obviously he was going to get caught and
get knocked out but he was so incredibly
fast for a big man he treated sports
writers with not contempt but you know a
certain familiarity which they did not
like they were gentlemen of the price
they wanted particularly black boxers to
be grateful for this opportunity to
become Americans and so in every way he
was offensive anything really the point
was he didn't deserve this fight in the
way a contender moves up it would be
just a little bit later as America is
pulling apart over the Vietnam War that
they pull apart over Cash's play than
Muhammad Ali but at that moment just
before he became heavyweight champion he
was this kind of cute kid who was going
to get his head knocked off I was really
sad but it'll be fun to watch run talk
about Ollie because I mean he is
somebody who you over the course of your
career you've kind of intersected with
at various points and you thought you've
been by story
yes since 1965 and how does he exemplify
a kind of change in American culture and
an American sports culture and the way
that we think about
sports well I'm watching idiosyncratic
because he really helped people like me
who wanted to write more social and
political aspects of sports and so he
brought all of that in I think in 1964
people saw sports as this sanctuary and
a lot of people still do sanctuary from
real life as its kind of this American
campfire where the whole family could
come together in its really
non-threatening way I think we could
fight about you know Mets versus Yankees
or red sari whatever but that's kind of
play boxing right it really didn't
matter as we didn't really have to talk
about the issues that we really saw we
did not talk about race class gender and
with it was a world in which women did
not exist we did not let women into the
press box much less the locker room no
place for women we did not cover women
sports I think that we were tolerant to
this is mainstream white America
tolerant to black athletes as long as
they hewed a certain line even Sonny
Liston you know thug that he might have
been huge that line he was the black
boogeyman that we had tamed right no he
wasn't mugging us anymore we put gloves
on him so so he's like mightyjoyoung or
something I mean he's a training yeah we
know we dragged him in from the jungle
but we owned him and so that I mean that
helps explain why the press as I'll
league up literally and figuratively
more and more outspoken as he changed
from Cassius Clay the Louisville lip
into this monster like a black man who
dared speak whatever he said I mean that
helps explain why sports writers were
like oh my god this this guy's insane
they had to say that you
I mean well they believed yeah what it
what if pull ropes would have become a
pro football player right you might have
had some of the same situation right
right beyond even issues of race you
know but also individuality and whatnot
I mean it's always stunning to me and
I'm about to turn 50 and I think of the
early ages of I can remember people
arguing about Jeff Frazier versus
Muhammad Ali and it only later did I
realize this was a proxy you know it was
a proxy battle for the proxy battle
between the Soviet Union and you know
America and Vietnam or whatever but also
people like Joe Namath and Johnny Unitas
I know it seems like a really stark
contrast and the sixties by the end of
the 60s suddenly athletes went from
being these kind of Lantern jaw
comic-book heroes who really didn't have
much to say but we're not threatening
and suddenly they're pulling on
pantyhose like Joe Namath or they're you
know openly sleeping with women and
wearing fu-manchu's mustaches how much
did sports helped fuel a kind of
individualization in American culture or
is it mostly that it was representing
sports
opened up to the black athlete mm-hmm
and Harriet was a well-known sociologist
was really the first to say that sports
and then America would take on the
values of the underclass because the
under glass was taking over sports and
he of course engineered or helped work
as straight the 1960 right the Block in
ghetto sports kids would wear argyle
socks in track meets to show a little
style
they were repressed in so many ways so
they would make these little movements
the whole you know quote schoolyard
basketball you know the slam dunk the
kind of flashy plays you know all
evolved out of black neighborhoods and
that eventually got institutionalized in
the ABA but Lena was treated as though
but really only now we're talking the
60s right where a basketball was
beginning to struggle between textbook
and schoolyard right
schoolyard being
was seen as part of the rebellion of
them you know college football players
growing mutton to us you know the fire
under coach and you would never get away
looking away you look like now you're
off the team are all I mean all these
things would seem so quaint
right and almost you know so and then
the way
Muhammad Ali Cassius Clay put down his
opponents no that's trash talk febre
trash talk is really the dozens and
joning which was you know a blacks
corner you one of the things that's
fascinating is for I mean youyou saw
Muhammad Ali as as a kind of cultural
change agent somebody much more
important than whatever those doing
boxing but by the same token and as much
as he pushed against White's area types
of blacks he also I mean and I think of
the way that he talked about your o
Fraser and he ultimately apologized for
it but he actually traded in the Crassus
kind of racial stereotypes that let's
not forget that the nation of his all
right was going up against civil rights
they believed in they were quite open
about they believed in segregation
he also made not so cryptic comments
that Malcolm X got what he deserved
right because by well I think that's
that's where Mohammed Ali and his
current wife and I have got some of our
issues I think that he was in some
abstract way an accomplice and the death
but when he said that anybody who defies
the Honorable Elijah Muhammad there
shouldn't live that was open she had he
held on to Malcolm even after his
apostasy I think that Malcolm would have
lived why did it take black athletes you
know say Italian athletes you know you
nobody expected Joe DiMaggio to you know
in a way he broke a color line in that
he kind of transformed her Hank
Greenberg I mean these white ethnics who
came through but you don't think of them
at all as ethnic now right it was that
the price of their admission to kind of
immortal status they assimilated you
know they were able to assimilate I mean
Hank Greenberg is a you know he predates
for Sandy Koufax's Hank Greenberg really
is the great Jewish jock and yeah so
we're gonna have to the super to Mike
Epstein was he was chill faking it oh
that's not take anything away over Mike
Epps do a look at his stats
yeah but greenberg really wanted to be
seen as a baseball player that was the
path to Americanism I I think in many
ways he may have been more even more
observant than Koufax neither of whom we
that they both was really secular
brothers and and DiMaggio was very
careful and Life magazine I believe it
was you know said something about that I
like most of his kind he doesn't talk
with my fans
what slurp and spaghetti yep so these
guys were up against Roy horrible racism
and they were very careful how much did
economic power I mean this is one of the
things that I think a lot of analyses of
sports kind of leave that we're you know
Muhammad Ali you can see him as he's a
great proxy or kind of personification
of changes in racial you know kind of
racial integration and questions about
that and kind of assimilation of some
degree of blacks into the mainstream of
American culture because he did by dint
of winning so many fights and coming
back again and again he became he's
everybody's all-american now in an odd
way but the economic power I mean people
like Joe Namath people like Dick Allen
Oscar Robertson Joe Pepitone even I mean
these were guys who were able for the
first time to really shake off a kind of
stultifying economic system where the
big team owners and the league's
really you know I hate sound like I'm
from the nation but I mean we're the
owners really sucked all of the surplus
value out of their players right and
that broke down and that seemed to open
things up can you talk a little bit
about how the you know the rise of free
agency in sports mirrors you know larger
shifts in American culture well I think
I would go back even a little further
back into the sixties together right
we're the quintessential sport I think
was tennis now tennis players were
amateurs with no reward
and how did they manage to live well
they were paid under the table to show
up at tournaments to win matches which
kind of kept them in total thrall to the
owners and the officials it was really
Billie Jean King more than anybody who
broke that system and brought us out of
amateurism into professionalization of
tennis and I think that was the first
big Howard she met how did she manage to
do that
by the ladies also a trailblazer and
other really and right by oh by
threatening strike the women wouldn't
play mm-hmm and they had very little to
lose they certainly weren't even getting
paid as much under the table as the men
were so that was an important thing and
and I think that there are you know
revolution starts small mm-hmm and they
start regionally no and I think this is
what happened in sports I mean all of a
sudden everybody else started thinking
you know I'm really being messed over
from the idea that you know the the team
that you signed with as a teenager owns
you for life front whether you don't
want to live in Philadelphia or not the
football players who saw that colleges
were quote stacking them that the
intellectual positions like you know
quarterback Center middle linebacker
could only go to white men run and I
think baseball the idea of you know this
plantation system most obvious so Curt
Flood run in the outfield or an
outfielder for the st. Louis Cardinals
who was traded to Philadelphia didn't
want to go
and he called himself a $90,000 a year
slave which of course the sportswriters
Oh laughter $90 but of course he was
yeah and I think that that resonated
with black players or he lost his case
to the Supreme Court but eventually a
few years later it was two white players
who were able through arbitration to
create free and reservas messerschmitt
and dave mcnally talked about Billie
Jean King a little bit more because you
said that you know in a lot of ways her
role in tennis you know are kind of by
threatening to withdraw from you know
her services which people wanted to
watch you know that helped gain she got
some economic power which changed things
he Elda the the ultimate feminist power
is too old so she's like the Lay's
estrada of tennis okay and and then she
emerged later in the 70s I mean she had
that great spectacle with Bobby Riggs
where you know he was the male
chauvinist pig
she beat him in a singles match and in a
lot of ways that singled signaled if not
parity between male and female sports
but a fleeting well it gave enormous
impetus to the ultimate enforcement of
title 9 mm-hmm so Billie Jean King
besides she's my favorite athlete
growing and I think the most important
of my time mm-hm
but you know not only did she I think
break open this you know amateur this
religion of amateurism is still very
dirty part of sports but she was
representing at least half the
population of the world women yeah part
of taking control of their bodies you
know was taking control of their sports
possibilities and then she took it even
further because she also took control of
her sexuality in a public way of saying
okay well I'm not I'm not gonna go along
I'm not gonna go along to get along okay
for I mean I I think she was in the
closet and she was she was kind of
unfortunately outed in a palimony run so
I mean I think she came out before her
time right but nonetheless and that's
interesting that she may be more rep
her exemplary than even Mohammed on lap
service of just the great
individualization American culture of my
past and I think in many ways that was
kind of hard core and real muhammad ali
really has to do with your feelings and
the emotional and political
sensibilities you attached to him right
Muhammad Ali again idiosyncratic and not
like anybody else also made people brave
I think that was his most important
function was a symbolic function
I don't think laws were changed because
of him but I do think that certainly
among young black men we saw this
beautiful black man standing up to the
man right among athletes you know who
when he was when he refused to step
forward and be drafted he was
immediately are some awesome for three
and a half years and athletes all over
the world saw well if they can do that
to Muhammad Ali they can do that to
anybody
so either we roll over and play dead or
we change the system and athletes being
you know risk-taking people the Black
Power salute the 68 Olympics came out of
a Olympic movement started by the
sociologist Harry Edwards that included
a number of demands some Olympic base
but one that Muhammad Ali get his
license returned to fight so this was
all part of what was then called the
athletic revolution and the black
athletic revolution which failed
Muhammad Ali has until very recently has
never made any of you know Michael
Jordan kind of money and the two young
men Tommie Smith and John Carlos were
effectively squelched with men
many years so but I think that everybody
saw what had happened and a new and
stronger generation came out of going a
little bit earlier back in the 60s you
co-wrote Dick Gregory the best known as
a comedian Dick Gregory's provocative
controversial best-selling autobiography
which he called [ __ ] right my
understanding of this that he had said
his mother asked him why he would ever
name his book that and he said something
along the lines of you know if they're
gonna call it to me if they're gonna
call me that anyway they might as well
advertise my book the opening of that
book and what's interesting is that
Gregory is in many ways an interesting
confluence of a political of somebody
who became a political activist started
out running on a track scholarship but I
think universities other Illinois which
is effectively the South talked a little
bit about your participation in that
book in the writing of it because that
opens and it's it's somewhat hard to
find and people are reticent to even
talk about it because of its title but
the opening section of that is this
incredible great set piece of black rage
where Gregory actually talks about his
upbringing and is particularly mad at
his absent father can you talk a little
bit about how you came to be involved
with that project and how how the
writing process on that work well Greg
had had turned out every other writer in
New York for the project and so the
publisher was scraping the bottom of the
barrel and they found this kid on that
rewrite again and sent me over to his
hotel room the day after the Birmingham
bombings when these four little girls
were killed I got there and I was told
Greg was in another room and couldn't be
bothered
I saw upside in New York Times and so I
walked in and sat down here's this man
in his underwear blubbering on a bed and
he looked up and he began for the next
maybe four or five hours
people like you murdering those little
girls so I I really got four or five
hours of that that black radio and I was
stunned
I listened to it I think that was the
beginning of our relationship
my father was head of what was called
the 600 schools schools for emotionally
disturbed boys primarily black in New
York City as I would visit him in
schools right and he was he really was
not a leftist but he was certainly
believed in social justice and and what
was happening to what he called the
underserved population so between my dad
and and Gregory that was a white boys
education and what was really happening
in the world so so Greg was a is a major
sports fan right and so we talked sports
a lot do you think race relations have
improved significantly since the you
know since the 60s and what was the role
of sports in kind of creative not
changing things but creating a place
where people could talk about this yeah
I think it has if no were the reason
then until he died a couple of years ago
my closest friend was black and we never
would have really gotten together or
found found ways to make the you know
initial contact if it hadn't been for
change and for sports and being able to
have this you know non-threatening
water-cooler to hang around I think that
Jackie Robinson certainly gave people an
opportunity to start learning how to
love and hate african-americans
individually rather than as a group so
it is still okay to hate black players
on the Boston Red Sox particularly yes
but it's because the Red Sox yeah but
III think that that might be a little
racist yes I think you want to hate
everybody we haven't come anywhere near
where she will we should be of course
we've come a long way is it because of
sports I don't know Harry Truman
integrated the the arms run first so
there were a lot of and that's very
important bread certainly there were I
had army friends you know who were close
for the moment so III think that you
know yeah sure all these things have
helped and sports has helped as well
these sports is also often all sorts of
bad values well let's let's talk about
that because in I think was in 66 or
thereabout you wrote a book called the
masculine mystique and this is a you
know a kind of fascinating counter not
to feminism but really kind of an
acknowledgement that there were kind of
crusty codes of maleness that have
certainly changed you know enormous Lee
what what what it means to be a man now
is very different than what it meant in
66 much less than 46 or 1906 I'm not
sure that that has changed for the
better by the way okay well let's talk
about that because you know among the
ways that sports promote bad values I
mean one is a and you've written about
this a kind of sense of entitlement it's
very much where you get to be the Prince
of the world and you know everything is
just for your taking because you're good
at hitting a ball or you know throwing a
pass or something like that so talk a
bit about the nature to talk about
sports and and the changes in the 60s
was kind of the the dyeing sensibility
that sports was a crucible of character
that it was within sports that boys
would become men and and women would
become spectators and women would learn
to serve them properly you late that
changed but at the same time you know
when I was growing up in the
these a man's was somebody and this goes
back to the frontier was somebody who
protected and provided for his family
and other people's little children
he was stoic and brave and he had all
these kind of good qualities whether he
did or not didn't matter that
sensibility existed I think that
sensibility exists now and with these
these banksters on Wall Street I mean
are these men Jamie Dimon is a man in
this society you have to be joking was
john d rockefeller a man oh absolutely
not
he took advantage of all these people
who believed in you know this idea you
know which never truly existed I mean as
we know Daniel Boone and Davy Crockett
were basically real estate speculators
which I'm not necessarily against what I
was gonna say at least unlike Jamie
trying to sell something uh you know I'm
always trying to sell if you're not
selling your missing business but I mean
at least Rockefellers sold cheap oil to
people in a way that Jamie Dimon it
remains to be seen what product will
save his well as a defender yes very
much so
but and and also one who's not related
to it by the way sadly but then talked
about in terms of sports figures I mean
because even Babe Ruth who was obviously
a philanderer and in many ways a
horrible human being his public image
was that of you know kids stay in school
you know even orphans like me if you
work hard and you know keep your nose
and now we have you know there's reality
shows about cast-off NBA not even wives
necessarily but baby mamas has sports
fueled that kind of sense of but
simultaneously male entitlement and
total lack of respect is fueled the
entire gilded age that we live it now of
course sports is part of it I mean I
think something happened
you know towards you know the the the
the dark part of the agency and
self-ownership among athletes was the
enormous commercialization and
commodification of sportswear sports
suddenly became an entertainment the
sport yes was always an entertainment
but it really you know had to have some
sort of cultural socio character
sensibility you know we were rooting for
our alma mater or where we want it to
have gone right or something that
represented us in some way the best
example now is the rise of fantasy
leagues which as reason readers probably
know better than anybody is where people
pluck run real players and create their
own teams out of them oh it's like their
automatic come to life yeah very often
to gamble on or for you know commercial
reasons but that's as far away as you
can get from rooting for something that
has some meaning do you do you feel that
sports as it's actually practiced by you
know grammar schools and high schools
and town leagues is that a has that
become a destructive force overall in
America who large extent you know I mean
there there are there are really
terrific coaches around on the youth
sport I've seen them there's a positive
coaching alliance that there are really
organizations are trying very hard to
stem this tie but if you see this pot of
gold at the end of the athletic rainbow
you know you know some years ago well
you try really hard to get into a
Division one school so you had a chance
at the pros now you try really hard to
get into a good beauty league for a tour
rolls or a good elementary or middle
school lead so you have a chance to
advance you have kids you know hurting
themselves I mean this this epidemic of
brain trauma which we're seeing now you
know it's ridiculous to lay it at the
feet of the NFL didn't happen there you
know it happened when the kids were
eight or nine in beginning those little
insults to their brain do you assume
that football is basically on a death
Deathwatch that's sometime over the
future I mean it don't almost be like
boxing or heavyweight boxing where it
starts to fade I don't know boxing died
because there were no more charismatic
mm-hmm heavyweights although every night
it seems to me also that they shifted
into things like mixed martial arts and
all the deities yell that reason because
all these you know they were not going
into boxing these cars right now began
to go through mixed martial arts but I I
think that people love to watch the
violence a football and football really
is the last bastion of masculinity faux
masculinity in America I mean you're
gonna be SEAL Team six sniper Rhett's
mm-hmm before there's going to be yeah
female linebacker right so this is this
last chance to watch these really big
guys you know will the crap out of each
other
it's very exciting so is it on its
deathbed it would be on its deathbed if
decent parents and grandparents didn't
allow their little boys to become P
reason didn't allow them to play tackle
football so we're 15 or 16 if ever and
it would be on its deathbed
if millions of fans you know a conscious
struck and say I you know just for my
pleasure
I can't watch these wins so in other
words you're saying it's not on its
deathbed at all how many people have
say you know we've had enough drone
strikes right well they're getting there
you know we had a 13-hour filibuster on
it so maybe Rand Paul needs to
filibuster that awfully it could happen
to the Year 50th anniversary s you have
written in favor of paying college
athletes or of rather changing the
college system so that maybe you don't
have to go you don't have to waste a
couple years and possible injuries in a
college setting where you're really not
getting paid much talk a little bit
about that and why is that so
controversial I I think it would be a
death knell to the football factories to
those institutions of higher learning
that have mortgaged their souls through
their stadiums and their teams they
found out and it really works I mean no
truth it was a beautiful example of a
good very good university that's really
known run for its football team more
than for its research facilities or its
library I remember once we set up a
camera on the campus near the grotto and
explained for some of the viewers who
are not privileged enough to grow up in
a Catholic verse what the grotto the
grotto is is it's really a religious
grotto where you can go and pray but you
know more stunning to a non Catholic
than that is overlooking the stadium is
this giant fresco of Jesus with his arms
out which is known a note among the
cognition he has touchdown Jesus so we
shot a hundred boys walking past and
perhaps 98 of them had first heard about
Notre Dame watching or listening to
games with dad I mean that would explain
why the kind of I guess you know people
who run Notre Dame and people who went
there would be against paying athletes
because then you know their business
model is kind of screwed but why are so
many sport it seems like many sports
writers are against the idea of paying
athletes what they actual
you know some large portion of what they
deliver in terms of spectator value
where where does that come from well
you'd have to talk to those dummies
yourself III think that may they are
still invested in some sort of I was
gonna say 20th 19th century model of
what Sports is about and what they are
covering I mean I think a lot of them
and when we talk about Shriners we're
also basically talking about all these
people who and particularly in smaller
markets but anywhere who are invested in
one way or another in the team which
gives them their their city and
themselves and their station or their
paper some sort of quote major-league
status you know where Michigan State may
be the main employer in town at hard
times there we lost his job too so III
think that that's you know it's that
kind of corporate journalism it's all
mixed into that you also are rare in
speaking non-us not uncritically but
positively about performance-enhancing
drugs and steroids you yourself you've
talked about and you've written about
your battles with cancer and the way in
which steroid treatments allow you the
user and why why are
performance-enhancing drugs
seen which have been in sports from the
beginning I mean you know there is no
Tour de France without enhancement you
know performance-enhancing drugs going
back to the first or second year of that
race but you know now it seems that you
know the worst thing in the world that
an athlete can do you know they can
train as much as they want they can lift
weights as much as they want but if they
take a pill or shoot something that's
verboten where where is that coming from
well you know it's taking the pill or
shooting something that enables them to
trigger as artists Iran I mean I could
I've been shooting up for 20 years I
still can't crush a fast
the I guess it's an aspect of control I
mean the anti-doping wonk somehow moved
in you know it's a way of controlling
athletes I mean I cannot believe that
the NFL you know doesn't paddle on a
river of steroids
run how could that be so big so fast so
powerful but I think that the
anti-doping forces or the NFL or
whatever has decided you know let's
let's not go there
baseball it didn't really matter that
much I mean it doesn't seem as if
attendance has dropped as home one
homerun output seems to have dropped in
recent years do we desperately need the
higher faster bigger through the greater
bangs of the spectaculars that we seem
demanding of these guys and the owners
are demanding run of their play and the
players mostly are willing to do this
are you kidding they'll do anything I
mean on that level run number one
they'll do anything to stay up there to
get up to that level and to stamp hello
and secondly I've talked to a lot of
players about this I've never ever had
somebody say you know I do it that's a
bad thing I feel badly about it but I
want to stay in the bigs nobody sees
there's anything wrong with this I mean
you know you're supposed to have LASIK
surgery for your eyes you're supposed to
do all kinds of supplements you're
supposed to kill yourself in training
sacrifice so many aspects of your
personal life what's the big deal and
meanwhile these actors that we love to
hobnob with you know they've all been
fixed I you know body modification is is
the future right do you think people
like Mark McGwire Sammy Sosa Barry Bonds
should they be in the Hall of Fame
despite
you know Alex Rodriguez despite
obviously having use
performance-enhancing drugs at least in
some cases in contravention of existing
baseball policies first of all I don't
vote you're very grateful to work for
the New York Times who you're not
allowed to vote because that was seen as
a conflict of interest second of all
what's the Hall of Fame what the Hall of
Fame is is basically an almost hundred
percent jump in the value of your card
and of your appearance and card shows so
is it Nobel Peace Prize I care about
that let's face it about yeah but so I
mean that you the Hall of Fame is one of
those are you arguing that it's kind of
one of those last word outs where people
can pretend that you know kind of
politics and meaning doesn't intrude
into sports yeah I mean it's like it's a
boys never
I have no opinion it's a tree house but
I've not been invited to you you've also
managed for essentially the entirety of
your career to be a novelist
particularly a young adult novelist your
first book I believe her first novel was
The Contender which came out in the late
60s or maybe six and is you know widely
read still you've done other books since
then what got you into writing young
adult novels and you know what what what
pleasure to get from them what function
do you think that well I had always
wanted to write fiction that's what I
know started out doing
that's right became a sport I've always
wanted to write fiction and one night at
a Muhammad Ali fight an old boxing
manager told me about three flights of
stairs up to his gym that he owned years
before and that someday he would hear
those steps of a hesitant kid coming
alone at night and that kid desperately
wanted to be somebody and would come up
these dark stairs because he wanted to
be
a contender I the image just totally
inflamed and then that became a book
about a young black boy he was
struggling between the kind of
discipline it takes to be a boxer and
other pursuits and you've raised several
it was a good boxer right but it was
that discipline it turns his life around
and I wrote it and at a time that they
were inventing Harper & row at that time
Harper Collins was inventing this new
genre young adult fiction
it was linear a seventeen-year-old
character there was no sex in it I only
wrote about what I knew at that time and
so they made it into a why a novel and
it was right for its time but what
happened was up until that time I've
been a sports writer for around ten
years by then up until that time I was
either a genius or a jerk mm-hmm
depending on whether sports fans agreed
with what I was writing but with this
audience and I went into schools because
I think was important for some reason
teacher saw it was important for kids to
shout white protagonist was black and
and these kids were so open about the
characters he talked about my characters
as if they existed and he argued with me
about things that my my characters had
done it was absolutely thrilling
experience to realize that there were
these people out there who could
appreciate this fiction on that level
I'd written old adult fiction with less
success and also that you could really
kind of reach out and touch a kid change
I mean so after that it took a while
before I wrote another one but it's been
a constant friend I still do it you know
talk about one fat summer which some of
us are fond of as well you know what was
the genesis of that and get well when I
when I was 13 14 years old I was very
fat I tell kids I had my own
code gets less and less of a laugh
that's right yeah
and but it was semi-autobiographical I I
lied about my age at 14 I had this
terrible job cutting grass man's yard
and in the course of that summer I lost
maybe 40 pounds I don't know because I
had come to a point where I didn't weigh
myself anymore I was afraid I was
hitting 200 already and and I always
wanted to write a novel about that so
for many years I wrote I was writing by
14 hours of writers would you say that a
theme throughout all of your work is one
about kind of personal control or self
control I mean it's kind of inch and I
hadn't thought about that before but in
many ways the way you talk about sports
professional sports but also in some of
your fiction that seems to be a
recurring theme the importance of
learning how to discipline yourself I
wrote a novel which pretty much banned
everywhere called Raiders Night Football
novel primarily banned because it was
the dark side of high school football
that this is not a good a good thing to
do when someday ESPN my high school for
the torch and I'm not familiar with that
but what's the plot operator well the
plot is you know a kid sees the team
hazing somebody into a great you know
break down run and so he's torn between
doing what I could have considered the
right thing and what would have been
best for the team is keeping it
suppressed but the point was that around
the country there are these kind of
Maverick football coaches who signed
this book and I'll go anybody who does
I'll go out there and talk to the team
and what's so interesting in that same
idea of you know kids taking why a
fiction seriously is the battle on the
team between whether or not my hero did
the realistic thing and you know half a
key that is so messed up you never do
that you take care of yourself man
that's what sports is all about does he
know you're a captain you're a stand-up
guy you do the right thing you take care
of little people and it was kind of
thrilling because it kind of I would
like to think it's recapitulating some
struggle in our society but I don't see
the good side of what's right right you
know reason loves economics we like to
talk about economics and the way it
infuses things that don't you know don't
present themselves as such with sports
has you know in the past let's say
before free agency broadly speaking and
this may be simplistic or just wrong but
you know the owner is basically they got
all the money you know fans paid
relatively small prices for tickets
the athletes got screwed the spectators
got what they wanted the owners got a
lot then with free agents get that much
okay what who the okay I mean to a large
extent and now we're talking you know
yeah 50 60 s many of those owners had
their team as their primary business and
source of income
that's hardly run the case now run of
the players tended to live in the same
neighborhood as their middle-class
families I always had winter off see
those on the selling aluminum siding
insurance right now pressing your
casinos directly so and the fans could
generally take the whole family to a
ballgame now then after this I mean it's
clear that you know owners make a lot of
money with their teams and despite every
year every NFL team you know somehow
loses money every major league team you
know in any sport loses money but they
do pretty well this the athletes do very
well even the mediocre athletes have a
collective bargaining agreement that
works for them and the fans get screwed
arguably in two ways one is that ticket
prices are massively expensive and then
also as taxpayers does it includes even
people who don't give a [ __ ] about
sports
is that the way that Sports has grown
is at this I mean like grown into a huge
global business that it's really
extracting money from taxpayers through
various kinds of subsidies I mean is how
big a factor is that and that's an
enormous factor yeah I mean the for
starters even if a team loses money and
I would have to see the book but I mean
other than Green Bay you know they're
all you can't see the process of any
football team even if it's losing money
what does it do for Domino pizza run you
know which is the main business of the
guy who owns the stadium you know
whether it's entertaining people in his
box no larger visibility becoming a
power in his community and being able to
ram through that bond issue which means
that you and I pay for the ballpark you
know with even more luxury boxes yeah
that's what's happening in in sports as
Sports becomes this entertainment
conglomerate
with lobbyists I mean yeah NFL has
lobbyists and the NFL is a nonprofit
corporation that's where sports is and
fans complain and so they'll watch the
games on television on ESPN for which
they are paying higher premium rates to
their cable server is there anyway
what's what's a possible intervention in
that so that just to bring it to a kind
of elemental soft social justice that
people who like sports pay for them and
people who don't don't have to pay for
them I think that's fair enough I mean
I'm less sympathetic with the fact that
you know and of course you're a couple
hundred dollars to take your kids to a
ballpark that's it that's a choice and
you can have your priorities don't don't
go to so much opera which is also by the
way taxpayer subsidized and really
expensive lutely I'm much more concerned
with taxpayers subsidizing ballparks
that they may not use well we'll end it
there
I want to thank Robert Lipsyte the
sports writer assumed to be ESPN's next
Ombudsman for talking with reason TV
sports which means talking about race
class gender and politics
Bob thanks very much race thank you
thank you
[Music]